McCarthy former Speaker of the House
slightly more conservative than the
previous speakers of the house than the
previous slimy establishment in DC
McCarthy just Endor Trump will Donald
Trump be the nominee yes and the
Republican party yes and if Biden stays
as the nominee for the
Democrats I believe Donald Trump will
win I believe the Republicans will gain
more seats in the house and the
Republicans will win the Senate can he
count on your support yes that's an
endorsement I will support the president
I will support president Trump would you
be willing to serve in a trump cabinet
in the right position look if if I'm the
best person for the job yes look I
worked with President Trump on a lot of
policies I we work together to win the
majority but we also have a relationship
where we're very honest with one another
this is the GOP establishment coming to
terms with reality Now Kevin McCarthy
has supported Trump in the past and
Trump has supported McCarthy in the past
and I've said it before this is always
my caveat I know McCarthy's very
unpopular Now by establishment standards
he's about as good as they get